you can go without food a week and you  will be hangry but you can go without  food for a week you can go without water  for a week and your kidneys will start  to shut down but you'll rehydrate and  you'll probably be okay you go without  sleep for a week  you will be very close to dead my  college student patients they're always  sick around exams when they're not  sleeping and for a lot of my patients  with crohn's disease and ulcerative  colitis with complex autoimmune diseases  if the sleep is off they'll have a flare  more than anything else more than their  diet more than stress more than anything  else is really the sleep  you see it you're you're run down and  you're more likely to get sick and we  know that sort of in the back of our  minds intellectually right that when you  run down you're tired you're not  sleeping well you're more likely to get  sick but I think we're not aware how  profound  that impact is